tonight we continue our reporting in our
series about the future of the family
farm this evening correspondent Doug
mackelway on the struggle to preserve
not just a livelihood but a way of life
this hey it'll be too long before we get
a cut it it size wheels cowboy boots now
a springtime delivery for Virginia's
Wilmont farms this planter puts 16 rows
of seed into the ground an upgrade from
the last one that's seeded 12 every
little bit helps to stretch razor-thin
profit margins for this 100 year old
family business I'm fourth in line and I
hope that my son will be fifth or my
daughter either one or both I don't know
that they will if you think about the
complexity of the equipment which often
costs more than everything else a farmer
might own including the land itself the
unpredictability of the seed stock and
the weather so many things can go wrong
the numbers are startling according to
the chairman of the House Agriculture
Committee over 12,000 US farms went out
of business in 2017 net farm incomes
have dropped 52 percent in the last five
years bankruptcies are up 33 percent in
the past two years and not long ago two
key universities and forb dust that
two-thirds of the representative farms
that they use to model economic
conditions of that culture are currently
marginal or poor financial condition
worse yet uncertainty of crops and
profits coupled with the social
isolation of farming contributes to the
highest suicide rate of any u.s.
occupation even if they're very
productive farmers things just start to
escalate to having cycles of anxiety and
stress and depression the new farm bill
just passed out of the House Agriculture
Committee yesterday addresses many of
these concerns expanding access to
credit and loans and expanding crop
insurance to include private sector
innovations one amendment the stress Act
would provide counseling to distraught
farmers WP Johnson is willing to accept
all those stresses for the life he's
chosen it's much blood sweat and tears
that I've put on this place
you have a hard time to get me away from
it I really do enjoy what we do here I'm
proud of it
but it's it's a tough life it's not all
gloom and doom frustration with city
life and the movement towards organic
and locally grown foods is sparking a
renaissance of young farmers using the
internet to market their products and
make a profit more on that tomorrow
Bret part three tomorrow Doug thank you